hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar
lyme disease past present and future i
am jennifer woods of labyrinths and i'll
be your moderator for today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by lab routes and brought to
you by diasoren
to learn more visit diasoren.com
we encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you may have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box and click send
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for at the end of the
presentation
you may also submit any technical issues
here as well if you have trouble seeing
or hearing the presentation
please allow me to introduce our speaker
for today's presentation
raymond dotwieler md professor of
microbiology and immunology
medicine and pediatrics at new york
medical college
dr dottweiler's research aims to develop
new diagnostic tests for infectious
diseases
including lyme disease these new tests
will lead to earlier diagnosis of lyme
disease and enable prompt treatment
he has a long and distinguished career
with numerous clinical publications
he has participated in a number of
advisory committees
and study sections most notably the idsa
lyme disease treatment guideline
committee and he served as
co-chair nih cdc conference
on the laboratory diagnosis of lyme and
other tick-borne
infectious diseases please welcome dr
dottweiler
thank you these are my potential
disclosures
this is the first slide um the learning
objectives
of this talk are to give you a
background on the history
especially the laboratory diagnostics
for lyme disease the
standard laboratory diagnostic
currently is serologic assays the
history of this is actually quite
interesting
and uh we'll go over the history of the
origins of the two-tier
system and i was actually a member of
the
cdc um committee that put the two-tier
system
together and uh was my lab and
uh alan steerslav and ray ryan's lab
that really were the
mainstays of putting this together and
then i'll discuss
uh modified two-tier testing
and its impact on diagnosis and
treatment
and then we'll try to give you a hint
about
where we are and what the future
research
is of as far as laboratory diagnosis
so the the history of lyme disease is
actually quite interesting
it's not a north american disease it
wasn't
uh discovered in the 1970s in
connecticut
it was really a disease that originated
in europe
and that you see that there were a
number of descriptions
of erythema migraines the classic skin
lesion associated with
this infectious disease presented
in the early 20th century the first
well-documented one
was in um
sweden in about 1909
the first uh documented
cases of erythema migrants
in the u.s were actually reported in
wisconsin by
a dermatologist scamenti
later on two dermatologists working for
the u.s
navy reported a cluster of erythema
migrants
in southern connecticut and then the
famous
uh description was by alan steer and
other
of his colleagues at yale and they were
really focusing on
an unusual cluster of arthritis
in old lyme connecticut hence it got
then got the name
and they popularized it uh
initially it was classified more
as a rheumatologic disorder by steer
but uh it became recognized that
it's really a systemic infectious
disease
and it's much more than just
a large joint arthritis
a breakthrough came when willie
burgdorferi and his colleagues
identified
a new borrelia species in uh 1982
from uh exody's ticks uh collected on
eastern long island
and those collections were made by jorge
banash's group at stony brook
um a year later uh
jorge isolated
this spirochete from patients
with lyme disease this was done also at
stony brook
and so that is sort of the background
of where it where it came from and where
it is i think that's
probably new information for some people
so if we look at the laboratory
diagnosis of lyme disease
um it really
begins with the discovery of berelia
backdoorfury
and it allowed for
the development of crude uh
whole borrelia burgdorferi ifas
that's immunofluorescent assays
analyzers and they just
grew the bacteria in culture and either
incubated patient serum with the whole
organism or
uh just ground up the organism and put
it on an eliza plate
that was not
terribly satisfactory because
the um
[Music]
false positive rate in
those early tests was terrible so the
predictive value
was really quite poor so
then um dressler who was working
uh with steer came
up with uh western blot criteria
and all he did was looked at what
bands were commonly showing up in people
with
with lyme disease and that was the
establishment of the so-called dressler
criteria
which was used by cdc committee
as the bands to look for in a western
blot
so to
really improve the uh specificity
of this whole process
the cdc committee said well we'll have
a crude first tier
essay that's really sensitive so we're
not going to miss
anybody that has it but we're going to
derive the specificity from the western
blot
so the western blot was put in place
because of the
poor specificity of first-year assays
and then it became codified as
the two-tier system
and that was done at the um uh
dearborn conference and that was cdc uh
really
spearheading that so
now these serologic assays
it was a lot of problems that
we now know that whole bacteria contain
many
epi epitopes that's antibody binding
sites
that are common to other bacterial
species
so we have a lot of binding
of antibody produced against other
infectious diseases the other problem
was
and i i got caught in the sensor
and that cultured bacteria can lose
plasmids
that are encoding key uh antigens
so so you keep it keep this bacteria in
culture for a while
as you pass it it becomes almost an
empty bag
and uh we didn't know that in the late
80s
and i thought that
we had surnative disease and really in
retrospect it was
not that the patients weren't making
antibody it was that the
bacteria had lost its ability to produce
the
key antigens another thing that's
important is that cultured bacteria
do not express a full repertoire of
bacterial proteins so there's key
antigens missing but from cultured
bacteria
so it was in this background that the
dearborn conference established
the protocol that we
still use today and that's a standard
uh two-tier system and that
again this was solely because of the
poor
specificity of first-tier assays
now at the time that of the dearborn
conference
we didn't think that we were going to
have
western blots for a long time we thought
this was an interim step
and we said that well there's going to
be new
uh improvements that will
allow us to move away from western
blotting
and
what we thought would be is you could
replace
um either the first tier or the second
tier
or maybe even both get rid of it and
make it a single tier assay the
caveat there was before new
tests could be recommended for
diagnostic testing
their specificity and sensitivity and
precision
had to be equal to the two-tier system
or better preferably better obviously
so it's with that background that
uh things have evolved and
in all honesty i'm surprised that things
have been evolved faster i think most
people were
because at the point of the dearborn
conference
um we thought progress
more progress would be made so it
is another problem with uh burleigh bird
gopher
it expresses different antigens at um
different phases of of its of its life
so it it really is adapted to a number
of different
environments there's the environment of
the tech
because it is a tick-borne disease so it
expresses
uh some antigens
in the tick it expresses some antigens
as it as the tick begins to feed and
then it expresses
uh other antigens during the course of
infection
so if we look at the outer surface
of the bacteria in the unfed tick
the major uh protein on the surface is
outer surface protein a
uh as the tick begins to feed
the production of outer surface protein
a
is down regulated and the
bacteria expresses outer surface protein
c and that's what
is uh the spirochetes that are injected
into the skin by the feeding tick
uh have on their surface once the
infection is established in the
mammal or human humans or mammals too
then it we get another shift in the
outer surface proteins and vlse becomes
prominent but that's only
after the establishment of infection
so if uh does
we look at these antigens that are
listed here
what it gives you some idea of the
molecular weights on there
and um we can see
that there is a an evolution of what's
expressed during different courses of
infection
early means erythema migraines
intermediate means a few
a week or two later and late is
obviously
uh months
later primarily this was worked out with
erythema migrant serum uh disseminated
or um erythema migrants term or
convalescent
serum and then people with uh late
manifestations either
arthritis or neurologic abnormalities
so the western block criteria when they
were first developed um
well crude and these are the bands that
are
and this is a typical um western blots
one of the things that we is should be
made clear
is none of these bands are specific i've
heard people
refer to a western blot is the patient
had
x amount of specific bands
well none of these bands are specific in
fact
virtually every one of these proteins
has cross-reactive epitopes and that's
an epi one or more epitopes that
are shared or common to other bacteria
so we really had not characterized uh
all of these proteins at the time these
these these uh criteria
were made and i think that people don't
realize that they think it's specific
it's not
and there were no imbibo expressed
antigens that were
put into this criteria now
that was a 1d gel that i just showed now
if we look
at 2d gels we get a very different
picture you have this idea that it's a
single band
on on on the 1d gel but when you look at
a
as a 2d gel what you see is it
is that many of those bands are not just
one protein they're a number of proteins
and this this was a slide that was
done in the early 2000s and
published so
to say that anything was
what it looked like on a one day gel you
know this was
uh uh c or this was
uh uh flabby
which is 41 you can see
that there's other things in those
regions that
could cause a problem the other thing
that's important to realize
is that many of these are
are pretty cross-reactive
flaw b is where which is flagellums very
cross-reactive
uh flhf is very cross-reactive
so that you have to be careful when you
when you're doing that
so this is another 2d gel this is just
later
disease and it again
shows essentially the same thing
the locations of the
key antigens are labeled here
and again there is a multitude of
uh overlaps so you can see that uh
ospay and uh uh
other antigens are along the same
band on a 1d gel
so that and again it goes to the
concept that none of these bands on a
on a western blot are specific
there you don't know whether which
protein
is is being picked up by the
patient's antibodies so there's uh
that is uh a concept i think that's very
important for people to realize
and and i don't think it's well
understood
so if we look at the impact of the uh
dearborn conference it did what it was
supposed to do
we got um much more specificity
in our testing protocols after the
introduction of the western block
criteria but
um it was certainly not totally
satisfactory because
there were issues with that system
especially in early disease it's really
not very sensitive
in in early disease and that promoted a
myth that there's a delay in the immune
responses
in prevalence or and that's not true a
lot of that is because of the
antigens that were in these assays and
as if you recall from an earlier slide
there's a limited number of antigens
that are expressed at the beginning of
the infection so the immune system
needs to
be able to recognize those make an
antibody response
and those and those antigens have to be
in the
assay that's why if you look at
sensitivity of
crude whole beryllia it's better than
some of the other things and
that's an issue so one of the things
that
was the next major
advance was the recognition of the
in vivo antigens
and the key one was vlse and dlse
is expressed after the establishment of
infection
and so may it becomes the the major
protein on the surface of the bacteria
uh the uh sixth
uh conserved region of the lse is called
c6
and that was promoted as a
very sensitive and specific uh
antigen that's proven
not to be the case although it was
really thought for a while and it was
hyped
as such so um
in um we sort of went along
and there are were a number
of meetings
to discuss things about how could we
improve things
and one of the key meetings was
co-chaired by myself and by barbara
johnson who was head of the
cdc uh serology labs
and uh that was held at the banbury
center at cold spring harbor
in 2007 at that point there was a real
push to make c6 a single tier assay
but it was
a lack of agreement mainly because i
could not duplicate
some of the studies that were uh out
there on c6 in my laboratory so
i was opposed to that
so the other thing that the things that
were uh
discussed at that meeting was the
specificity of two-tier testing for
uh igm and it was felt that igm was
a pretty sticky molecule and that
wasn't really
living up to what we wanted there was
real specificity problems
the uh other thing was that this
sensitivity
that i mentioned is was very low in the
earl in early infection
using the the two-tier system
uh standard two-tier system so
we said him we would like to do better
uh but that the once
uh you start looking at igg
which is after three or four weeks of
infection and
this system was performing pretty well
uh and that was
no firm conclusions were made at that
other than highlighting these points
now one of the things that became
obvious
um during this time frame was that
there's a lot of
energetic cross reactivity in
the standard two-tier assays
and this is just a a list of some of the
worst ones and if you look at
um the flagellum which is
at 41 kilodons
there are studies that show up to uh
40 or more of normal healthy individuals
with no history of lung disease have
uh antibody against 41. uh
that the the uh antigen at 60
uh also was highly cross-reactive
uh that the an antigen at uh
30 kilo domes uh was uh is homologous to
uh an antigen uh found commonly in gram
negative bacteria
and uh also there were studies that came
out that demonstrated that
um the wholesale sonicates
uh when used as first-year assays
uh had a tremendous amount of
cross reactivity in tropical regions
where there were no lyme disease
so that was just some things that were
highlighted
uh during that time frame if you look at
flagellum if you look at the epitope
mapping
you quickly see that there are
variable sequences and conserved regions
and domains that are semi-conserved
so there's areas that are
really quite cross-reactive with all
other bacterial flagellums
but there are there's at least one
epitope
in 41 which is specific more specific to
borrelia and
that was something that we noted in my
research group
and have focused on
looking for more specific epitopes
within uh these individual proteins
if uh one of the bands on
the western blot is at 66 and we
looked at uh that and we found that it
was
very highly cross-reactive and this
slide is taken from the paper that's uh
referenced here and um
so when you start to think about things
if you're looking at a western blot well
you have multiple bands on that western
block
that are not specific and uh
41 66 60
which could be mistaken from uh 58
so you can see where you could make a
lot of mistakes
and um
the western blot becomes much more
difficult to work with
so uh after the uh
establishment of the uh peptides
c6 what became next
and the answer was
we began to really drill down on
the epitopes of each of these different
antigens and looking for what was
cross-reactive and what was
more specific and
the peptides now have become more
important
and you're starting to see the use of
them and the two prominent ones right
now
are still um uh or
c6 and then another uh peptide
pepsi 10 which is from see
oscar c um
c6 is now somewhat out of favor
and the c6 assay
has largely been dropped
but it's c6 is still
contained within a number of different
commercial products that are out there
they're used in combination
with other antigens
now getting to c6 one of the things that
was initially said about c6 is that it
was
extremely well conserved and that
it was could be used in north america or
in europe
europe has a different situation than
north america does because
in north america we have a very
limited um diversity of genome species
in essence we only have we have one
major one and one minor one
but in europe we have an array of
different genome species
and these are the amino acid sequences
of
uh see the c6 region in the various
genome species and also
uh there's the amino acid sequence
of borrelia miyamoto
and miyamoto is is
a relaxing fever organism
and so now what we now know
is that relapsing fever organisms
uh are cross-reactive
with the uh brailler door for eye sensor
stricto
c6 sequences and that is
one of the reasons why uh
c6 is no longer
favored as much as it had been
now if we look at other um
antigens which are commonly used well ac
is a very key antigen
and it's very good uh for detection of
early
uh infection it's as you remember i said
earlier
rc is expressed on the surface of the
of the bacteria as it's introduced into
the skin by the feeding tick
so one of the first antigens that
the human immune system sees is rc
it also sees the flagellum antigen
and some others but if you look at us
c it too has a number of different
um epitopes
and it's got two it's got pepsi 10 and
it's got we
labeled this as a pepsi
one but it also has a cross a cross
reactive epitope
which is uh you can see in the middle
here
so um but all in all i see is a
is a nice antigen to have in your anagen
mix
but again this highlights the uh the
fact that you've got
specific antigens and non-specific i
mean
specific epitopes and not specific
epitopes within
each protein now alan
barber pointed out something that also
is very interesting
and this is goes back to c6 c6 is a
single epitope assay
so it means it's got one
[Music]
antibody binding site if you
look at assays the assays with
multiple antibody binding sites or
multiple epitopes
they have a better signal to noise ratio
and that's what this slide represents
as you move from
one or two epitope assays
to five epitope assays or even
greater your signal to noise ratio gets
much better
and that's one of the reasons why
multiple epitope assays are better than
a single epitope
assay and i think that's a point that's
important so if you look at something
like if you just combined
rc with pepsi 10 it's not going to be as
robust as
something that contains multiple
epitopes targets so now
what's happened uh since uh
all of this well really we have a number
of
papers that have shown you know
potential epitope targets
but a key development was also
uh the development of
what's called modified two-tier system
and
um uh that was fda approved
you know two years ago and that uh
has allowed us to um
fulfill what we wanted to do in the
first place and that's moved
on from western blotting
so if you look at
where this originated from
branda had started publishing about this
and
really as far as 2011 was one of his
early papers
and what he showed is that if you took
uh two
first tier assays and compared them to
standard uh two-tiered testing
that you were able to get more
sensitivity
in early disease and that was one of the
things
if you i said earlier in my talk about
the banbury conference
that we wanted to do that we
really recognize the poor
performance of the two-tier system
in early disease
and the other thing
is that it had very good
results in
later disease both convalescent
and in late disease
so that was the beginning and obviously
that
was developed further and um
again this is another paper uh
oh the same paper by brenda and he we
looked at
not always he looked at not only
sensitivity which was the first slide
but now the uh specificity
which was the uh second slide and
remembering that the two standard
two-tier system was put in place
because of uh the necessity
to make uh specificity better
and what you see is that the
results of his uh modified two-tier
system
gave very good specificity results
both in symptomatic controls healthy
controls
and
really quite comparable
now that was just using uh
one possible two set of
you know two tiers and since then
uh he's gone on uh and others have gone
on to
look at other things this this slide is
a study out
of cdc in which they looked
at various uh
modified two-tier possibilities
and also compared it to uh standard
uh uh two tier and they looked at
um uh two different types of western
blotting in
in this the one one was mar blot and the
other one was ferrostrip
um and there is variation
in which western blot that that you use
a lot of problems with western blotting
and consistency but the bottom line on
this is what what
you can see is that
both of the modified
two-tier systems that that they used
whether it was
wholesale followed by c6 or whole cell
followed by vlsc you got
better uh sensitivity in
early erythema migrant patients
uh even in convalescent it was it was
better and um uh
so again we're seeing uh a
major flaw of the standard two-tier
system
being um improved upon by this
so um and for for that cdc study the
specificity was actually quite good so
it's another study by uh brandon
in which he looked at the various
combinations
both first year alone and the modified
protocols and again
this just showed that he had
good uh sensitivity
and good specificity across the board
and i think it's important to note that
in the disease controls and what they
use is disease controls as things like
rheumatoid arthritis cases or
cases that might be
mistaken for lime in some ways and you
see
that the uh the wholesale elisa really
doesn't perform very well
c6 and vlse also have
some cross reactivity but uh certainly
not uh of the magnitude of the whole
cell
uh assay and that the um uh
when you use the modified two-tier
system that got cleaned up pretty well
so uh uh again
that reiterated that this could be
um used to fulfill the criteria
of bad that was established back in
1995.
so this is another uh
uh study that was done uh by um
uh cdc and and again
we're seeing that it's pretty
uh consistent and they dropped the use
of the mar block
in this study because marblet did not
perform as well as the veristrip
in their in their studies and again
they're pretty consistent with the the
previous slide
in which the uh
modified two-tier system works really
quite well
and um
eventually this led um the
uh fda to be uh quite amenable
to looking at the modified two-tier
system
and why uh they
felt comfortable approving this modified
mind to to a system
now um
that brings us up to now so
certainly there are two manufacturers
that are
uh that have modified two tier uh
systems uh on the market in in the
united states
that's zeus and diocerine and
they they differ a bit um
i think a head-to-head test i'm not
aware has been published
at this point there are pros and cons to
various approaches the
use of pepsi 10 is a single epitope
antigen the use of c has
um multiple uh uh epitopes
uh so you your signals and noise ratio
is going to be better with it
oh although uh a whole
uh rc is gonna have some
some additional cross-reactive epitopes
that you wouldn't see in pepsi 10.
the
nice thing about the two-tier system to
modify two-tier system
is it eliminates the the western bloc
and you hear very often that
uh well i get more information out of a
western blot
i doubt that i i've heard that from
experts like alan steer and i have
actually discussed that with him i don't
think so
i mean i i've been in this business a
long time
and i can tell you that reading
uh western box is hard and uh
you're really getting a lot of
information
that you think you have but you may not
is
the uh of all the mess that's in there
so for the average person
i would say the western blot
is difficult to interpret and is
frequently over
interpreted uh again
the the bands
are not were not characterized when this
criteria was put in
uh and that's an important that's a very
important point
the um current
thing is that the
modified two-tier systems are working
at least as well but i think better than
uh the standard uh uh first tier essay
plus a western blot
and uh that's important
the other thing that's that's important
is that
you're you have out there people
that have their own western black
criteria or so-called lime specialty
labs
and fallon published a study
on them and they they are not performing
very well
um so i don't think that uh
juggling criteria for the
western blotting is makes any difference
it just makes things worse in my opinion
the other thing too is there are
again i can't reiterate strongly enough
no specific uh bands on a western blot
that
would make you think uh that someone has
lyme disease or you shouldn't think that
um i've heard people say why don't we
have uh
ospay as as as in the band criteria
and aspe is not expressed in in vivo
until
late in the course of disease and then
rarely
and um the
committee that established the two deer
system standard two-tier system looked
at
adding us ospay to the
western black criteria and it didn't add
anything it just added the confusion so
that's uh where we stand
will it be further improvements uh i
hope so
uh because um i'm working on it
um my prejudices are is that we can
uh put together uh
peptides that are
a number of specific
epitopes from various antigens and using
that
as a system but that's not
currently in use it's still in the
experimental phase
uh what else can be used well we can use
t cell immune responses to look for
exposure to this bacteria and
there is some preliminary data which
would suggest
that t-cell assays unlike b-cell assays
can predict outcome that your
t-cell immune responses drop off
after successful treatment whereas
antibodies once you make an antibody
response
you have it and there's no correlation
between
antibody responses and continued disease
and uh the fact is if you mount
a mature immune response you may have
that
antibodies in your blood for years and
years
and it has no correlation with active
disease or not
so uh i think
one of the problems i've seen in the
past is someone's had lyme disease
been successfully treated three years
later they have some other something
else some
someone draws a lyme serology it's
positive and
they start blaming whatever that the
clinical manifestations the patient has
at that point on lyme disease and it's
really can be quite
devastating because they miss
the real disease and treat someone for a
disease that they recovered from years
ago
so i'm optimistic and i think we're
we've made good progress and hopefully
this
has been helpful and allowing you to
understand
a bit more about lyme disease laboratory
diagnosis
thank you
thank you dr datweiler for your
informative presentation
we will now start the live q and a
portion of the webinar
if you have a question you would like to
ask please do so now
just click on the ask a question box
located on the far left of your screen
we'll answer as many of your questions
as we have time for okay let's see if
this
works going back and forth how has the
mtt
algorithm impacted lyme disease
diagnosis and treatment
well i think it's improved it
dramatically because one of the biggest
problems with the
the standard two-tier system is the
insensitivity in
early disease and by allowing
earlier die laboratory diagnosis
we can have more
treatment at an earlier stage and then
that's going to improve outcomes
okay wonderful let's see let's go to the
next question here
lyme disease serology in some circles is
seen as insensitive
can you comment on this well i think
that
the standard two-tier system was
insensitive
in early disease but it was really
always quite good in
in later disease um and that so that
um early in sensitivity
has sort of created the myth that it's
insensitive
at all phases of the infection and
that's simply not true
but now with the modified two-tier
system we're gonna
we're overcoming some of that issue
all right wonderful we have another
question coming in
do you see a role for pcr in diagnosing
lyme disease either early
or late disease um not really i mean pcr
is more expensive
and the only time you can really
get accurate pcr would be early disease
pcr and skin biopsy or
[Music]
theoretically if someone was
back to remix and and that's just a very
transient thing
so pcr does not play that greater role
i know some people use urine pcrs or
blood pcrs
there's a lot of inhibitors in urine and
in blood and
pcr is just not very practical
for this disease
gotcha well thank you so much dr
datweiler um
do you have any final comments for the
audience today
well i think that you know we can now
move away from the western blot and i
think that that's an important
contribution
so i think the western blots created a
lot of confusion over the years
and as i've tried to point out there's a
lot of people who
believe in western blots and over
interpret them
and you have to be quite careful so
the standard labs using the modified
two-tier system
probably is the way to go and get away
from
using uh either people who purport to
have some uh expertise in western
blotting or
western body in general
well thank you again oh go ahead no
i hope i hope this uh was educational
for
for everyone i'm sure it was we have a
lot of
great questions still but we ran out of
time
so thank you again um dr douttweiler for
your time today and for your important
research
we would also like to thank labyrinth
and our sponsor diasoren
for underwriting today's educational
webcast before we go
i'd like to thank the audience for
joining us today and for their
interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
this webcast can also be viewed on
demand
lab routes will alert you via email when
it's available for replay
we encourage you to share that email
with your colleagues who may have missed
today's live event
until next time goodbye